[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRICE CHALLAMEL: So Kendrick,
you have an amazing life.
You started selling caviar in
high-end places in Las Vegas.
And now you propose shares
of Ample Food, which
is an organic brand of food
that is widely democratized
and distributed through
micro-investments
on a very sustainable platform,
leveraging blockchain.
And you have a legal background.
You are a former
fellow at Stanford Law.
And you could, on
your spare time,
but you don't want to say it
in front of everyone at Google,
right?
So that's basically
a few things--
KENDRICK NGUYEN: I would say
I'm non-technical, particularly
in this room.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
So the first thing
I want to ask you-- because we
just used a lot of buzzwords
there in a very few sentences.
It's a story of four dogs.
So there is a dog from
AngelList, a dog from the tech,
a dog from Wall Street,
and a street dog, right,
or a normal dog.
And the dog from
AngelList says, you know,
when I want more
money, what I do
is that I leverage
tokens from a blockchain
to do micro-investment
in startups.
And the dog from tech says,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
what's a micro-investment
in a startup?
And the dog from Wall
Street says, hold on,
what's a blockchain, right?
And the dog from the
street says, what's money,
because he hasn't come up with
a lot of money in his life.
So this is a-- you
know, I don't want it
to be a dog-eat-dog situation.
I want us to understand every
dog's perspective in this.
So how can you make it clear
to every perspective that we
can have on this what
you're doing exactly,
and what your company--
because you're
an entrepreneur, a
founder of Republic,
which is a part of AngelList--
what your company does
and that every dog
would understand.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: I
love that hypothetical.
And I think when it
comes to investing,
it's definitely not
dog-eat-dog, and it's
more like dog-feed-dog
world in this one sense.
I think the easiest
way to look at money
is that it's a form of energy
and a medium of exchange.
Today we use dollar here,
the pound in England.
But anything can actually
be a medium of exchange.
So you need money
to drive that energy
and grow an idea into a
business, condition necessary.
The question is, how do you
get more people to do that?
And how do you break this
energy down to smaller pieces?
And if you can do that
through blockchain technology,
then you have that much
more energy directed
into this ecosystem,
and net-net, more ideas
will grow into more businesses.
So the way I look
at investing is
that, if you manage to make
and to encourage everyone
to invest even a tiny amount of
money into this whole ecosystem
and direct that money to where
they believe the future should
be in terms of entrepreneurship,
and companies, and product,
then we're just going to have
that much more prosperous
of an ecosystem overall.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: OK, so
the micro-investment part,
I get from this.
How about the blockchain part?
Like, why would you use
blockchain for this?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Currently,
the reason why would take--
it would cost, probably,
about $20,000, $50,000 minimum
if you want to invest into
real estate, even a REIT,
is that the cost
of transferring--
of making it possible
for people to buy
a lot of-- a stake in a building
or a home would be so high.
The cost of processing,
of validating,
of confirming your
interest, and when
you want to sell
that interest is
going to be equally burdensome.
Blockchain technology--
one use case of it
is fractionalization
and automation.
If you can break the "Mona
Lisa" down to a billion pieces,
you can have a billion people
around the world owning
a piece of the "Mona Lisa."
Yes, it's only worth, probably,
a fraction of a dollar,
but you're owning a
piece of the "Mona Lisa."
And that's only able recently,
through blockchain technology,
that you can fractionalize
things to that degree,
and that it costs
next to nothing
to transfer a tiny fraction
of an asset between two
individuals.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: I have a
feeling Leonardo da Vinci would
have loved your idea,
right, and be very
interested in the mechanism.
So what I get from this is
that this micro-investment,
which is a form of
expression of crowdfunding,
but more organized, right,
more on a platform--
you're standing somewhere
between crowdfunding
and an IPO, right?
There is this middle
space that has not really
been invested-- if I might
use the word-- before in which
initiatives need money.
And why wouldn't you
come at this earlier
than the formal IPO, which
return investment might not
be so high?
Because now there
is the technology--
and if I notice where, also--
the regulation for this.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Early
investing naturally
comes with higher risk
and much higher return.
So I think most people
nowaday, in this ecosystem,
know that Uber is
about to file for IPO.
People who are
buying in post-IPO--
pretty much anyone who's
not a millionaire--
will see a return or a
depreciation-- but, you know,
2x, 3x, or 20% loss.
Obviously, if you invested
$10 in-- or $100--
into Uber's very first
round on AngelList,
today, that's going to be worth
somewhere between $1.5 million
to $2 million on face value.
So getting in early is
definitely a value proposition.
But it wasn't legal until 2016.
Up until two and
a half years ago,
you got to be a millionaire to
invest in private companies.
And I'm glad that the world
is very different now.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
All right, and so
that's when your legal
background comes into play.
Because you knew the
law had just changed,
and they'd opened a huge
new opportunity for people
to invest.
Because they don't
need to have--
to be certified investors,
if I get this right.
And so then, the
question is, how do we
organize this to work
efficiently for everyone,
right?
Am I right in this?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Absolutely.
So obviously, the law
is there to make sure
that people aren't now they're
defrauding grandmas and people
with very little
dispensable income.
Now on the other hand,
99% of the world--
of the United States--
wealthiest country
in the world--
99% of people have never
made a private investment.
So they don't know what it is.
Everyone had taken
a cab or a taxi--
almost everyone-- before Uber.
So when they made it possible,
it was just a natural leap.
What we're trying to
do is to get everyone
to do something that they
have never done before.
So it's a much more
challenging journey
from the branding,
marketing exposure,
as well as legal and business.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right,
so I went to your platform
as part of the
preparation for this talk.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Thank you.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: I discovered
the breadth of products
that you have there.
It's amazing You go from
Ample Food, which I mentioned,
to some more tech startups.
Can you tell us, how do
you curate the properties?
Because I still want to know
that my dollars are invested
in a place that is kind
of safe are curated,
and I think you
provide that service.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Given that
AngelList is our institutional
co-founder, and our team has a
heritage back to the venture,
the VC lens--
so we do apply
some natural lens.
Is there credibility?
Founders have domain expertise.
On the other hand,
I fundamentally
believe that people
should invest
for any number of reasons.
Maybe they just want to
support women founders.
Maybe they want to get some
return back from that food
truck and not necessarily
1,000x in a tech company.
So if the vision is to build
Amazon for private investing,
where you have
thousands and thousands
of companies, and millions
and millions of people
participating, then
one of our core focus
is to present as many options--
credible, viable options-- as
possible, and let the crowd
follow their heart
and their head,
and make the decision
for themselves.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right,
so I got a better idea
of what you do at Republic.
You allow everyone to
make micro-investments,
even a few dollars,
without overheads,
because the technology is
there, without legal constraint.
Because the regulation
has changed.
And there's this new highway
of potential investment open.
However, my mother told me
never to gamble, you know?
And I don't know that
I've been such a good son.
But what would you say
about the risk-reward?
And is this for everyone?
Or is this something that--
how do you reassure
me that you're not
about to create the next
subprime crisis with your idea?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Of course.
You know, even when
it comes to gambling,
it's not so much that
you should never gamble.
I think that people
should do whatever
it is that they
want to do if they
are fully aware of the
risks and the consequences.
So you know that
gambling, likely,
is going to result in
total loss of money,
but you have a lot
of fun doing it.
And you can afford that $50 at
a slot machine, by all mean,
in my opinion, you should do it.
Obviously, the risk of
gambling is very high.
Now when it comes to
early-stage investing,
the risk is still
high-- not as high.
But every single year,
about $100 billion
are being spent at a casino--
not by millionaires, mostly
by non-accredited people--
another $80 billion
into lottery tickets.
Can you imagine what the world
would be-- what Silicon Valley,
and the US, and the world,
at large, would be--
if 10% of that $180 billion
per year would get invested--
or gambled, informally--
into new innovations
that has that opportunity
to change our world?
BRICE CHALLAMEL: So
basically, you're
saying the micro-investment
is worth the risk.
What do you have to lose?
It's a few dollars.
What is the average amount
of people-- that people
spend on your platform?
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
If I may take the--
answer one question
about money, this
is more like my personal view.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Please.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: I
think, generally,
from what I observe,
how people spend fall
into three categories.
One is the basic
necessity, you know,
putting food on the table,
buying toothpaste, feeding
your kids if you have kids.
The second one is for
enjoyment, for value.
You know, you go out
and buy a nicer jacket
you don't necessarily need.
You take a kite surfing lesson.
And the third one is for growing
that capital that will enable
you to do number one and two.
So obviously, don't
spend any money
that you absolutely
need to feed yourself
and your family in the
casino, or in investing,
for that matter.
When it comes to
micro-investing $100, $500--
investing, not
buying a product--
I think it's a blend
between two and three.
It is quite
satisfying, if I really
believe in that food truck
founder, and her food,
and her resilience
day in and day out.
And she decides to fundraise
to build a Mexican restaurant.
And I invest $200 into it.
You know, if she doesn't make
it, I'm still rooting for her.
Now if I'm investing
$200,000 into it,
I probably want to know that
I can get the money back,
or that she would do so well
that I could make two or three
times as much.
But when it comes
to micro-investing,
you're going to be--
you will be able to
let people gamble,
or make informed decision, and
have fun between two and three.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: How is it
different from crowdfunding?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Let me
give a very quick definition
of crowdfunding.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Please.
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
Kickstarter and Indiegogo,
whereby you go on and buy a
product that hasn't been made,
that's generation
one of crowdfunding.
And that's back in 2008 or so.
Then you have, 2011,
AngelList came into the mix.
That allowed millionaires to
co-invest into tech deals.
So that's the second wave of it.
And when Republic
launched in 2016,
that allows anyone, anywhere,
of any income and net worth
invest as little as $10
or $20 into businesses,
that's crowd-investing,
still crowdfunding.
I think all of us can
agree that there's
a different psychological
attachment when you invest when
you have an interest
in something
compared to buying a product.
I used to work for the guy
who founded SKYY Vodka.
And I don't think there's a
difference between Absolut
Vodka and SKYY Vodka.
But if you, Bryce, had made a
$50 investment into Absolut,
when you go out to the bar
with me at the end of the day,
you're going to buy
me Absolut shots.
You're going to serve
up that kind of--
that brand of vodka over
the holidays and July 4th.
So that notion of
engagement, of commitment,
of having skin in
the game, I think,
is what going to drive crowd
investing into a new trend.
And indeed, that's the
underlying foundation
of a token economy,
of using tokens
to incentivize participants.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All
right, so what I understand
is that crowdfunding might be
more before there's a product.
Micro-investment is at the early
stage when there is something,
and you know what
you're investing into.
But you still have
attachment, because you're
such an early
contributor to this
that you want to serve
that vodka to your friends,
or that strawberry juice.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: And that you
potentially get that return
in share in that
outsized growth.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
Because this is more
a return on
investment perspective
than the crowdfunding,
which may be just
you're buying something,
really, and paying for it.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Correct.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: And
it's still early enough
before there will
be a stock exchange
play that you have
the huge reward
curve if you are investing
in the right thing,
and that your passion and your
gut goes along with the market.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: 100%.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right.
So thank you for all
these explanations.
It's already very,
very interesting.
Now I would like to go
on the step further.
Because you are in the
middle of a lot of trends,
and each of them collide in
what we're doing right now.
How do you see the
future of investment?
So let's say that Republic
is the present of investment,
because I can go,
today, on Repulic.
It's republic.co, right?
So it's for everyone
who wants to--
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Not
dot-com, dot-co, dot-C-O.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
Dot-co, not dot-com--
all right.
You got rid of the M, all right?
And so republic.co--
and what your platform,
and how it works and operates--
so I understand the past.
I understand the present,
and this very new initiative
and interesting way to see it.
How do you-- what are
you going to launch?
What are you dreaming about?
How do you foresee the future?
What is your take on
the future investment?
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
First, let me just
share one tidbit about the
present and the funding
landscape.
I don't know how many
people, even here, at Google
and in the heart of Silicon
Valley, realize that 50%--
5-0-- of all venture capital
go to businesses in California.
Another 50% go to
just social apps.
African-American founders--
African-American women
founders--
are responsible for $30 billion
worth of revenue businesses
founded by
African-American founders,
are responsible for tens
of billions of dollars.
And statistically, 0% get
funded on certain years.
So if we can agree that
good ideas exist everywhere,
that no community,
no city, no heritage
has a monopoly on
innovations that, if funded,
can mature into the Google,
the Apple of the world
10 and 20 years from
now, then there's
a lot of work to get done.
So now to answer your
question, what's the future,
I think the future is, indeed,
that if not 80% or 90%,
then 50%, 60%, 70% of adults
would look at micro-investing
$10 and $20 at a time as a way--
as a new way--
as a new spending behavior
similar to, or adding onto,
whatever else
they've been doing.
Think of it as a
social engagement,
almost like
recycling, but adding
on to that potential
for growing the capital,
the savings that you have.
And I think-- there's
no question in my mind
that Amazon for
private investing
will be the future,
that people will
be investing as
easily, and quickly,
and cheaply as buying
a product on Amazon.
And once we get there, I think
we can eradicate global poverty
once and for all.
Because investing in a new
day and age, when technology
reduces, not
increases, jobs, how
do you lower the income gap?
By allowing people to
invest $10, $20, $30,
and have that opportunity
to get a major distribution
and realize their potential
in different ways.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Wow,
it's a pretty bold vision.
Thank you for sharing it.
One thing that I
forgot to ask you,
how do you make money
for Republic out of this?
How do-- how does your
system operate financially?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Well,
currently-- full disclosure--
we're about three years out.
And we definitely
are not making money.
We are completely
venture-backed, losing--
we're very much in the red.
Hopefully, one day,
we'll be making money.
But we have a cash commissioned
out of the amount being raised
as well as a small interest
in every single company
that successfully
raises on Republic.
So in a way, if one
of the companies that
had raised on
Republic, in 10 years,
does an IPO at the
size of Uber or Airbnb,
then Republic
would do very well.
Now, we're going
through an initiative
that we aim to tokenize
our future revenue
and give them back to every
user, and investor, and partner
on Republic so that, if and when
we get that major distribution,
all the hundreds of thousands
of early believers in Republic
can benefit in that
as well monetary-wise.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
So if I'm investing
in Ample Food and
Republic, I'm also
somehow investing in Republic.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Correct--
so currently, not yet.
Currently, if you
invest in Ample Food,
and if they get bought out
for 10x, and you invest $100,
give or take, you're going
to get about $1,000 back.
But very soon, we
will be giving--
for making an investment on
Ample Food, or in any project--
let's say 100 Republic tokens--
each token, at 1
point, will represent
a portion of future income
that Republic takes in.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: OK.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: So that--
imagine back when-- in the
early day, when Amazon just
had 10 companies
on the platform,
and they had given out a
billion tiny little slivers,
and each sliver
represent revenue
from each of the company, at
the time, it may not mean much.
But now, 20 years later,
it can be very substantial.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: So
that's very interesting.
Because what I understand from
this is that this way for you
to monetize your
services, for one thing,
tells us that you have skin
in the game of the companies
that are on your platform,
that you believe in them enough
that you took a small
share yourselves.
And the system also
allows you to create
the transaction system that is
completely zero-cost, right?
Like if I have a share of
any company on your platform,
and in five years, they are
really doing super well,
I can divide my token
in as many as I want,
because it's
infinitely dividable--
I don't know how you say.
You can infinity divide it--
and then transfer this
to anyone, globally,
in the world without
any overhead or expense.
Am I right in
understanding this?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Yes, how
much, or into how many pieces
you break it down, and
who to grant it to,
that's the realm
of token economics.
And there are different ways
of incentivizing people.
But absolutely, back
when Google was still
a private company, an employee
holding 1,000 shares--
in order for her to
transfer it to her sister,
say, in Singapore,
first, you got
to get the consent
of the company.
Then you have to go
through the transfer agent.
Then you have to sign, probably,
about four sets of documents,
both counterparties signing.
The company would need to do
a background check [INAUDIBLE]
on the sister.
And that's why that
process is so inefficient,
that transfer of private
securities, even today,
is heavily, heavily limited.
Blockchain technology and
the new application of it,
in the months and
the years to come,
will make that process even
more seamless than public stock
trading today.
And I think, again,
it will just bring
more of that energy that
feed into these budding
companies around the world.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: And I want
to talk about the offer
side of the equation.
So we were [INAUDIBLE] we
talked about how you orchestrate
the platform and what
liberated this initiative
on the basis of technology
and regulation changing.
We talked about the part of
the people who need funds.
We talked a little bit about
the part of the investors.
Let's say, tomorrow, I want
to monetize something that has
never been monetized before.
So let's take an
example that, at Google,
we talk about a lot--
or we hear about a lot--
which is our data.
People say to me, all the
time, how about my data?
It has value, you know?
And you use that value.
And there's a huge conversation.
Because I think they gain
value against that value
from using the
services for free.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: And it has--
it's a topic from DC, to Europe,
down to the private citizens,
right?
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Yes,
and right now, it's
a very top-of-mind topic
for everyone, especially
in this day and age.
So let's say,
tomorrow, populations
wanted to monetize
their data, right,
that they would say,
all right, let's
create a platform together
to put our data together.
Maybe individually, my
data is not worth so much.
But maybe as part of--
I don't know-- my income
level on the West Coast--
or I'm French, so as part of
the French community living
abroad--
or any identity,
maybe some companies
would be interested in
purchasing some of my data.
Could I use a platform
like Republic,
and the new regulation, and
the arrival of blockchain
to somehow put my data,
willingly, knowingly
on the market and decide how my
data is going to be purchased,
traded, bought, and so on,
in a way that I feel to be
transparent and empowered?
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
Absolutely-- certainly
not on Republic today,
because we're currently
more of an investment platform.
But there are two elements
of blockchain technology
that would, in my opinion,
solve, in major ways,
or in meaningful ways,
the data privacy concern.
One is that security,
but decentralized so
that you don't have to worry
about a central party holding
all relevant information
getting hacked.
And so that, in
and by of itself,
does ease the security concern.
And the second one--
one of the main--
using, probably, my own
psychological attachment
or assessment of this
particular data question--
and I think that even though,
yes, I agree to the terms--
but I didn't know why
that I was consenting
to providing all of these
personal information and data
to a couple central parties.
And I'm certainly
not feeling like I'm
being incentivized by it.
If you apply a token
economy around it
and enable people
to make money when--
or share in that
economic value of data
and a choice to opt
out, I think you're
going to get so much
opting in that, net-net,
it benefits everyone.
And it still serves
that same purpose
of using data to analyze,
to produce, and put out
better products that
serve human, at large,
as a community.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
All right, so I took
a very extreme case,
because it's very deep
materialized, people's data.
But what I understand from
this discussion up to now
is that the shift in
paradigm that you're here
to talk to us about is both
democratizing the investment,
and what is being
proposed for investment,
and creating this new
space in which people,
for the price of
a lottery ticket,
could actually apply
value to their values,
value to their commitments,
participate to things that
are already there and that are
already started and visible,
and gain the traction
of early investment,
and that this is probably
going to profoundly reshape
the way we create
monetization out
of various elements
of investment
that, today, are still
believed to be very restricted
to a system with a cost base,
with knowledge and
expertise, and that maybe,
tomorrow, all these things are
going to fly out the window
and will be available for a lot
of people, truly democratized.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: 100%.
I think the next Facebook--
the first investors
in the next Facebook
should not be
[INAUDIBLE] of the world,
but be the 500 door
maids of the founders.
Hopefully, it doesn't
have to be a Harvard.
It can be a women's
college out of Pakistan,
and that the next
wave of founders
can be a single mom in
Ecuador reading about it
and putting in $10 and
$20, and that by the time
the banks and the venture
funds, or whatnot, get in,
everyone else get in
more and more, and that
when there's an IPO
event like the one that's
going to produce 100,000
millionaires in the Bay Area,
that they're going to
be hundreds of thousands
of people benefiting
all at the same time.
So I think the last wave of
venture capital, the last 30
years it's produced--
has lifted 1.3
billion people out
of abject poverty in the world.
We've been living in the most--
in a better time
than ever before.
But much of the fruits of
it, in terms of wealth,
has gone back to the wealthiest
and the institutions.
If we can encourage everyone
and make it possible,
a small amount, for everyone
to buy in, I think the world,
20 years from now, will probably
be almost like sci-fi fiction
with very little--
you know, the wealth is
just across the board.
And the standard of
living can be lifted
from all corners of the world.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right,
well, thank you so much.
This was very enlightening.
I loved both preparing
this with you
and having this conversation.
Time for us to open to
the rest of the audience.
Any question, any
comment, anything
you would like to
ask Kendrick, please.
AUDIENCE: So I went
to the platform,
and there is one thing
I don't understand here.
When I invest a certain amount,
do I get equity in the company?
Do I own 2% of that startup now?
Or how, exactly, does that work?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: So each of
the deals on the investment--
and thank you so
much for joining.
Each of the deals
on the platform
has its own set of terms.
Some of the companies are
already venture-backed.
They've raised tens of
millions of dollars.
And now they just
want to bring--
provide an opportunity for their
customers and fans to get it.
So typically, it
would say a valuation.
For example, the
document would say
that you're investing
$1,000, and at the company's
valuation of $10 million.
So usually, with investing,
what that means is that,
later on, if Google buys
that company at $100 million,
then you would get
100x, give or take,
on your own personal investment.
So in a way, yes,
it's skin in the game.
It's buying in.
It's not sha-- there's a range
of distinction between shares,
and stock, and debt, and
save, and convertible notes.
But the general thesis
is very much the same,
that if the company
does well, you
will do well
proportionally so as well,
to contrast against buying
a product or making a loan
and get a fixed return back.
So sharing in that success
and that growth, I think,
is a psychological
satisfaction and validation
that a lot of people in
tech have experienced.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Has that
answered your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: And to
be very clear for anyone
who hears this--
because we all understand
the concept of share
and being a shareholder--
when I invest through
Republic, what am I?
And what do I have?
How do you call this?
What is it?
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
You're an investor.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: OK.
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
But in most cases,
you're not a shareholder yet.
You're just an
investor to make it
simple for the company
and the founders.
So in fintech, it's
a confluence of law
and regulations on the
one hand, and innovation
on the other hand.
So you have a set of laws that
was written some 80 years ago,
at a time when the
world we live in
wasn't even on anyone's mind.
And how to apply these rules to
make it possible for a world,
now, that you can have a million
investors at a very early stage
into it?
Because of that need,
the new instruments
like convertible notes,
like the save, et cetera--
but you're an investor.
Shareholder or not
is far less material.
But typically, at one point,
you will become a shareholder.
And then you get paid
out and cashed out.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right, so--
and what will be that point?
Like, when do you make the
shift from being an investor
to being a shareholder?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Yep, so the
instrument that we created
to make it possible for
founders and companies
to deal with so many
people is that, if,
and when, they experience
a "liquidity event,"
meaning a merger or
acquisition or going IPO,
then they will convert
everyone into shareholders.
And then, because you
are a shareholder,
you get paid out
or get cashed out,
and then leave the company.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: All right.
KENDRICK NGUYEN:
Because otherwise,
if you keep 10 million
shareholders on the cap table,
the cost of administering
it is exceedingly high
to comply with corporate laws.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
All right, very--
thank you so much
for the question.
Very, very good question.
And thank you so much
for your detailed answer.
AUDIENCE: I have a question on
ICO, Initial Coin Offerings.
Many startups are doing
that in the last few years.
And frankly, most of
them are just scams.
You know, they issue a coin, and
get $10 million, $20 million,
and they're not doing anything.
Then SEC start regulating
that for bigger ICOs.
So what's your view on
the smaller ones which
are still happening
in Silicon Valley,
and sometimes, in one world?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: I think
that's a great question.
You know when-- the
ICO boom in 2017,
in 2016, it gave all of us
at Republic warm and fuzzy
feelings all over, because it's
a true, real-life validation
of our model in the future,
where thousands of individuals,
and not venture capitalists,
finance random projects
and companies, not
here in Silicon Valley,
not out of Google, but can be
out of Singapore or wherever.
So crowd-investing, in its best
form, was ICO back in 2016.
Now it was done in
a non-compliant way
with US securities law.
So the law caught on.
And so now you apply laws and
regulations, many of which
are meant to prevent frauds
and scams perpetuated
on the investing public.
But it does come with
bells and whistles.
So it makes it a little
bit more difficult
for people to participate--
know your customer,
anti-money-laundering,
and whatnot.
So you're seeing, in many
ways, a healthy contraction
of that type of
financial product.
But at Republic, we're trying
to make that compliant and easy
and get back to one point when
a credible project can raise
$10 million, $20 million
without having to go and pound
the pavement on Sand Hill
Road because she happens
to be not living in America
and not economically
possible to do that.
So I'm very optimistic about
blockchain technologies
and startups that are built,
or leverage that technology
in the long run.
And Republic itself is
applying some of that as well.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Oh,
and I wanted, also,
to highlight something.
And I will just let
you answer to this.
But you could say, at
Republic, we do this,
and Republic could be only
you in a garage in Palo Alto.
Or it could be a bigger team.
So can you tell us
a little bit more
about under the hood, like your
organization, how many people
you are, where
they are located--
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Yes--
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
And [INAUDIBLE]??
KENDRICK NGUYEN: --definitely.
I was general counsel
for AngelList.
And we spun out and set
up shop in New York.
Because that's the seat
of the capital market.
And most people still have
never invested privately.
So our team are
probably slightly
different than a lot of true
tech startup in the valley,
but we're pretty
equal, purposely
so, between engineering,
business, and then obviously,
compliance being an
investment company.
There are about 50 of us.
Most of us are in New York.
There's a small office
in San Francisco.
Among the team, there's
seven former attorneys
turned business or engineer
to navigate this confluence
of legal and innovation.
And we have a mildly
distributed team.
But there's still a core
team based out of New York.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
All right, and here,
what I meant to get from
you, which I do get,
is that this is
not just you or two
or three people in a garage.
This is solidly enough
organized already
that you have some very serious
people in every department
of this making sure that this
work is sustainable, and is
efficient, and compliant,
and everything.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Oh,
absolutely, because we're
so heavily regulated for
touching retail investor.
I think we've been audited
something like a dozen times
by FINRA and the SEC in
two and a half years.
That's why we have so
many lawyers in-house.
We have, on the
business bench, people
who have background experience
at BlackRock, at McKinsey.
One of our founding
advisors founded
the Malala Fund, whose work
got Malala the Nobel Peace
Prize-- so influencers
and what have you,
Jason Kidd, the athlete, is a--
and Chamillionaire, the rapper,
are both advisors and
influencers for us.
So to do, and to
build on, this vision,
it takes more than a village.
It takes partnership
and the goodwill
of people across all
different sectors of society.
AUDIENCE: I know
that it's very hard
to determine a
valuation of a company,
particularly very early on.
So what is Republic's
involvement
in valuing a company
before they create
an offering on your site?
And how will that scale as
you have thousands or millions
of companies on your platform?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Thanks
again for the question
on valuation and due diligence.
So in the past two and a
half years, we've gotten,
I think, by now, almost
5,000 applications.
And we've done
due diligence on--
depending on the level of due
diligence, but on all of them.
And we've launched less
than 5% on Republic.
When it comes to valuation,
there's actually no real math,
particularly for
an early company.
Your valuation is
whatever investors
are willing to invest in you.
So we typically look at if
they have raised money before,
then use that as a
potential point of data.
If they have never
raised money before,
then we want to make sure
that it is at least in line
with the current ecosystem.
To give you an example,
YC startups typically
raise at about $10
million, $15 million
in valuation pre-product,
pre-market, just two dudes.
In New York, the same
team, out of New York City,
would be probably 25%,
30% less in valuation.
Because venture
capitalists in New York
aren't just as willing
to fund a company
that's valued at $15
million pre-market.
So applying all of
these relative lens
that we pass a reasonableness--
and it's still up to the
founders to do their work,
and convince investors, and
strangers, and families,
and friends to make
that investment.
AUDIENCE: Kendrick,
what are some
of the challenges of
expanding these investment
opportunities to international
markets outside of the US?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Thanks, Colby.
On our platform
today, the companies
have to be based
in the US for now,
even though we have partnership
with different platforms
in other continents.
But we have
investors from, like,
30 or 40 countries around the
world investing on Republic.
Going back to a
rather trite statement
that good ideas
exist everywhere,
I really look forward
to the day where
people here and in New York,
at lunchtime, go on it,
look at a bunch of companies
in Africa or Latin America,
and dish out a small amount,
and happen to build and make
meaningful businesses that
create jobs in those regions.
So the future is
very much global
when it comes to
entrepreneurship.
AUDIENCE: So you talk
about micro-investing
and invest $20 or
$30 per company.
But given the high risk
of early-stage startups,
one has to invest many more,
say, 100, 200 companies,
to average that rates in return.
So how do you think the
average John Doe can
manage such a large portfolio?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: When it
comes to the very high risk
of angel investing,
the name of the game
is diversification,
as you mentioned.
So on AngelList, as an
example, the minimum amount
usually is higher than $1,000.
But that lowest has
got to be $1,000.
That's a lot of money for
most people in this world.
If you can reduce
that down to $100
and allow $10 investment
into 10 companies,
that changes the
landscape of things.
And hopefully, at one point,
we can even bring it down to,
like, $5 and $2.
My family immigrated
here from Vietnam.
And I remember, when
we first moved here,
my mom used to send
back, like, $100
a month to a couple
of her sisters.
The transaction fee on that
transaction was, I think,
$13 or $14 to the sister in
a larger city and, like, $17
to someone in a smaller
town, which is absurd.
But it was-- that's what
everyone lived with.
Now, in a day,
given that Vietnam
is a very warm to
crypto technology,
you can make the
same transaction,
and the fee will be
less than a dollar.
So-- and we're two--
we're like 2:00 AM
into this new day.
So I have no doubt that
a couple years ago,
a person with a $50 saving--
not the money that she needs
to put food on the table--
would be able to deploy that
$50 into 10 or 20 companies
and still potentially get a
meaningful return out of it,
net-net down the road.
AUDIENCE: Is this
micro-transaction model really
better than the AngelList
syndicate model where you have
some professional that goes
in and vets the invest--
the companies a
little better first?
Because we know that even
some of the best investors
don't actually succeed
better than the S&P 500.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: The question
about venture validation
and elite investor
investing is addressed
in two different ways.
Just because you
allow micro-investing,
it doesn't mean that you
wouldn't have that validation.
So I think 27% or 28% of
the companies on Republic
had been venture-backed, so
already went through that lens.
Now on the other hand, the
problem with venture investing
is that a fund, like Sequoia,
would only pick startups that
they think, potentially,
can yield them--
the proverbial "unicorn"--
50x, at the very least, 20x.
5x-- not interesting.
It's not enough.
That fits into their
economic model.
If you have two
founders building
a business in East Oakland, they
will never be more than a $20
million company.
But that creates 500 jobs for
single moms in East Oakland.
And you happen to
just want to support
that particular business
and get 2x or 3x back.
Currently, you don't have
that avenue on AngelList
or with any venture fund.
So if you [INAUDIBLE]
entrepreneurship and investing,
it has to be--
Silicon Valley has done a lot
of good, but that's like V2.
We now are ready
for that next stage
that people have a say in
the type of businesses that
get financed and that will
create a world that we'll
be living in 10 years from now.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that Republic
will take a portion
of the companies that
are on your platform.
Can you share what that is?
And is that consistent
for each company?
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Yes.
So currently, I'm just going to
use a very specific use case.
So there's a company that
raised on Republic when we first
launched six months
out, and now she
has gone on to raise
additional capital from VC.
The founder, a Latina
mom who was working
for a corporate-- in
corporate for a grocery
chain, doesn't have a
technical background,
doesn't fit the lens of someone
who would get venture backing.
And she just needed
that $50,000, $60,000
to build out the first
model, hire an engineer
and a businessperson, and grow.
So we were like, all
right, we think that she's
incredible and resilient.
And her experience
saving money is
so relevant to
building a business.
So we launched a campaign.
And she raised about $80,000.
A lot of it was financed by
Latino-American professionals
in the Bay Area and beyond.
Out of that $80,000,
the time and money
that we've deployed
into it was probably--
I'm going to guess-- $20,000,
it being the very first project.
But the math is that we get 6%
out of the amount successfully
raised, so 6% of $80,000.
Plus, we get a security
interest in her company
worth 2% of the amount raised--
so in this case, $1,600
worth of her equity.
If she-- she's building an
employment training platform
that trains very low-level
employees to mid-level
management--
the shopping bag,
cashier at Safeway
and Lucky into
assistant manager.
If she somehow becomes
the LinkedIn of the world,
that 1.6--
that one $1,600 stake that we
have may be worth millions.
And if that's the
case, we're going
to send that back
to investors onward.
BRICE CHALLAMEL: Thank you so
much, Kendrick, for joining.
And I want to thank
you for two things.
The first thing
is sharing with us
your knowledge, and
your experience,
and your company's
history, and life,
and mission, which
was very interesting.
And the other thing,
also, is I want
to thank you for
sharing your story,
because it's very inspiring.
You, coming from Vietnam,
having grown to be a Stanford--
fellow at Stanford Law,
becoming an entrepreneur,
connecting back to the world,
giving it back to the world--
As you know, at Google, we
really embrace diversity.
We want not only
diversity, but inclusion.
Like, it's not only
you're in the nightclub,
but you're invited to
dance, right-- so inclusion.
And everything you say
spins a positive light
on the world, on how it's doing,
and how it's going to become,
and on these values
that we hold very dear.
And you're a living
example of those values,
connecting technology
to good business,
to good value and
initiatives from people,
respecting-- what we
call here, respecting
the opportunity, and all this in
great ethics and transparency.
So thank you for all of this.
This was a pleasure having you.
I'm so thrilled to
have had you today.
And I'm looking
forward to everything
that's going to happen for
Republic in the coming years.
And I want to wish you the
best of success with this.
KENDRICK NGUYEN: Thank
you so much, Bryce.
It's truly an honor to be here.
And I want to thank everybody
at Google for having me.
I think the model--
[APPLAUSE]
--of do good is something
that's close to my heart.
Google was the first company
that put do good together
with profit.
And that's what gave
rise to Republic.
And you know, on
the personal level,
it's, incrementally,
we do what we
can to live up to something
that you guys have perpetuated
all throughout the globe.
So thank you so much.
BRICE CHALLAMEL:
All right, pleasure.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]